We've seen what a negative exponent does to something in the numerator, it moves
the base to the denominator. So if a negative exponent moves something in the
numerator to the denominator, then a negative exponent in the denominator must
move that to the numerator. When we first saw negative exponents, we learned
that a base raised to a negative exponent, would be the reciprocal of that base
raised to its positive exponent. This can also work in the opposite way, like if
we have a negative exponent in the denominator. A negative exponent indicates to
write the reciprocal of the base to the positive power, so I have 1 divided by 1
4th, the reciprocal of 4, squared, I change the negative to positive. I know
dividing by a fraction is the same as multiplying by a reciprocal, so I can
rewrite this expression as 1 times 4 squared. And again, notice a negative
exponent in the denominator, moves the base to the numerator with its positive
exponent. We can use the same reasoning with variables. I see a negative
exponent in the denominator, so I know that this base is going to wind up with a
positive power in the numerator, y to the 5th. For this last one we want to be
careful, 5 has an exponent of 1, and x has an exponent of negative 4, so only
the x term is moved to the numerator. When we handle this negative exponent, we
rewrite our expression as x to the 4th divided by 5. In general here's the rule
we can write for base raised to a negative exponent that appears in the
denominator, we simply write it in the numerator, with its positive exponent.